Now, where were we with Grant? Oh, that's right, he was on the plane. He's on
the plane going from home to the Cxpo in the city Udacity. But Grant is super
impatient and he would really love to find out where the halfway point between
his hometown and Udacity is. He found out earlier that the exact distance
between these 2 points is the square root of 530,000, in miles, of course. So,
he just measure half of the square root of 530000 along this line, that doesn't
seem like a very exact or very easy to do either. But just by looking at our
graph, I'd like you to give me an estimate for the midpoint is. That is, what if
a coordinates of the point that's halfway between these 2 points along this
line?